Amanda what a worrying time for you and
family to tell us more about Debbie have
you been in touch we're one of the lucky
ones yes on Saturday my mum rang me to
tell me about the disaster I was
completely unaware and obviously we were
very worried for her safety she was
climbing Everest and she was at gorak
shep which is I think the last camp
before Basecamp one on the south side of
the mountain and I think potentially she
may have saved her own life because she
was suffering from acute altitude
sickness and therefore did not move with
the rest of the team and stayed there I
think with a Sherpa and three others and
and so therefore didn't make me make the
journey although from what we can gather
from this text they were affected by an
avalanche they felt the tremor so they
stayed put but amazingly I I just got an
email from her which is extraordinary
considering the awful pictures that
you're showing there that there's
there's actually 4G but she's she's made
it down the mountain to a place called
faroush I think that's how you pronounce
it where there's one place where there's
some internet to say that she is safe
and the three other people with her two
of whom are British I think are safe as
well so we're extraordinarily lucky
thank goodness for that I mean it seems
to me you recently got that email and no
contact in between the text message when
was out of the weekend and this email
exactly the text message was Saturday
morning and again that was to say that
she was safe and my mum and dad
obviously having extraordinarily worried
as have I my sisters very very capable
and I think we just took comfort in the
fact that we had even heard from her to
be honest because we watched we've been
watching sky continuously on a loop and
to see everything that's been going on
I'm just so grateful that she was even
able to get a text through to us it was
from some somebody else's phone I didn't
wreck we don't know the number tell us a
bit more about the trip Debbie was on I
mean for so many people this is the the
trip of a lifetime isn't it trekking in
the Himalayas some who was she with was
she with a an organised group she
was a very close friend of hers who
she's called Simona my sister actually
lives in Thailand she's a scuba diving
instructor so you can already tell the
kind of person she is she's adventurous
to say the least and this was a dream
she'd saved up and this was something
that she was desperate to do she sent us
lots of pictures over the last week and
we've all been you know laughing and
joking saying it looks like we're Elsa
and Anna live from frozen's my two young
children obviously they have we have not
shared the information that she was
caught up in this tragedy but you know
it's been a very sort of joyful
brilliant thing for her to be part of so
how it's gone this badly wrong is just
shocking to us and all of those people
involved well that's the point is now
Amanda our thoughts go out to all those
caught up in this and you know many many
thousands tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands affected absolutely and Debbie
Debbie's email said that she's trying to
get to all these other different
villages that she's just getting safer
and safer I think which is lucky but I I
believe that I think there are 70,000
people trying to get out of Katmandu so
I don't think we're going to see her for
a long time I'm just dying to hear a
voice to be absolutely honest with you
but as long as she's safe with as I say
we are very lucky there's so many other
British people who are waiting for news